ou vous autour de la table avant qu'on
interroge nos invités on va voir la vie
de tout le monde peut-on se moquer des
religions etc partager on a un 3 3 on
dirait voilà non mais ça c'est vrai
c'était un stade à manchester hier alors
vous dites non christine kelly tiens je
vais démarrer par vous
parce que c'est tombé sur abbas est
tombé sur moi bravo moi je dis non
pourquoi
je comprends qu'il ya la liberté
d'expression mais liberté d'expression
n'est pas liberté d'agression c'est la
raison pour laquelle on peut rigoler de
tous à partir du moment où ne blesse pas
l'autre ne blesse pas son prochain
rires oui blessé non et je vais me baser
moi qui suis une ancienne du csa ne
serait ce que sur un petit article sur
la publicité à la télévision qui
interdit toute publicité qui peut
heurter toutes convictions religieuses
droit la saison et un article noyelles
quantique loval haquin interdit toutes
les publicités à la télévision qui
peuvent heurter toutes mes convictions
religieuses je me base sur ça pour dire
que oui à la liberté d'expression
on peut rigoler on peut rigoler de la
religion mais attention liberté d'
agression non alors éric de haut
peut-on se moquer des religions oui en
france on a parlé tout à l'heure d'un
symbole de la france qui était notre
dame et deux autres symboles ya la
liberté d'expression et le fait que le
blasphème n'existe pas mais à ce que
propose christine c'est assez redoutable
parce que la vexation s'est pas
seulement pour les croyants faut donc
interdire tout humour qui vexerait qui
froisse ray ou une quelconque personne
donc c'est fini
faut abolir l'humour moi c'est pas dans
ce monde là que je veux vivier pas dit
vous continuez à vivre ensemble même si
le fils y avait je veux continuer à
vivre en france je veux continuer à ce
que certaines blagues ne me fasse pas
rire en france on peut sauver notre dame
et on peut se moquer de notre dame comme
l'a fait charlie le lendemain de
l'incendié au logo de surlendemain il
c'est ça qui définit la france donc
c'est un autre pays que tu veux moi je
veux rester dans ce délire patrick
peloux a failli venir nous voir
voilà qu'on embrasse patrick que j'aime
fort et malheureusement il n'a pas pu
aujourd'hui il fera peut-être d'autres
balances ton poste avec nous monsieur
laporte donc jamais d'accord avec moi je
veux vivre dans une société où on rigole
où on se moque au bon sens du terme il
n'y a pas d'agressivité dans le sport on
se moque des positions dans les
vestiaires les bichonne
dans le sport et le rugby et mosport ya
de tout il ya toutes les religions
confondues il ya des petits et des plus
grands il ya des gros etc et on rigole
sans arrêt et chacun d'eux se moque de
l'autre en permanence mais c'est ça fait
parti d'un bien vivre ensemble c'est pas
de l'agressivité c'est comme tout à
l'heure c'est qu'elle s'est fait avec
avec prb ce calme avec rire avec
dérision avec seymour ça passe bien
mieux qu effectivement quand c'est de
l'agressivité à gâteau totalement
d'accord avec bernard et je crois moi ce
qui se passe quelque chose de très grave
c'est qu'on se dirige vers une société
de l'indignation systématique et de la
censure et de l'autocensure
ce qui est très grave j'ai l'impression
qu'on ne peut plus rien dire plus rien
faire sans se prendre immédiatement des
réactions disproportionnées de tous les
côtés parce que on aurait été trop loin
ou heurter quelque peu en fait derrière
l'humour la dérision c'est pas un crime
l'humour c'est pas un crime on a pris
l'exemple du tweet du gros et en plus il
ya eu un déferlement sur ce twitt mais
je crois que personne n'a eu la
référence de la vanne qu'il essayait de
faire ce qu'il a fait référence à une
souris que personne d'ailleurs moi
j'adore cette émission mais moi aussi
j'adore mais n'ont pu devenir père joe
personne n'a compris la vanne personne
ne connaît et hugo mais juste parce
qu'il s'était emparé d'un symbole
religieux
tout de suite il il a été taxé de
racisme l'islamophobie d'agression alors
que l'humour n'est pas une agression il
n'y a pas de message cheminots dernière
s'il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de volonté de
division au contraire c'est une volonté
de rire ensemble et je pense que si
chacun faisait preuve d'un peu plus de
dérision sur soi même mais on serait
tellement on sentirait tellement mieux
mais tous dans la vie en communauté
alors j'aimerais dans la vie de jimmy
également de modèles de mohamed dû me
mohamed qu'on soit vraiment dire non
c'est son nom est serré que sont famille
s'appelle jimmy et une famille chez moi
mais j'adore vous êtes mon idole voilà
je vous ai menti alors vous pour ces
crimes arsac c'est une position
compliquée à défendre passementiers
alors d'un côté on aurait la bonne
société prôné par eric naulleau qui me
dit que si on veut pas de celle ci bat
finalement est un peu des terroristes
intellectuels et qu'on voudrait vivre en
iran ou en afghanistan
c'est pas du tout ça mais six ans c'est
un peu ce que tu sous-entends moi je
parle comme un enfant tu pars pas la
belgique
tu parles d'un pays évidemment
yousfi le blasphème n'existe pas donc on
a le droit d'insulter une religion mais
on entend beaucoup d'humoristes dire que
l'humour s'arrête appartement vous
blesser les gens et moi c'est vrai que
quand on parle notamment des communautés
j'en ai marre des blagues sous
d'asiatiques
ce n'est pas la longueur de leurs easy
sur le fait qu'ils travaillent beaucoup
moi ça me fait pas rire j'en ai marre
qu'on se moque des maghrébins en disant
voilà la boîte à ma croûte quand ma mère
n'est pas d'argent bah oui votre maman
l'a pas eu d'argent je vais pas citer le
comédien qui fait beaucoup de blagues
sur ses parents mais je trouve pas ça
drôle
j'en ai marre qu'on se moque aussi des
noirs j'en ai marre qu'on se moque ça me
fait pas rire parce que c'est un fonds
de commerce
ils ont besoin de le faire des gens ont
le droit d'y aller c'est la liberté
d'expression de la même façon moi je
suis blessé quant aux joies alors
charlie hebdo c'est très compliqué de
parler du charlie hebdo bien sûr je
cautionne pas ce qui s'est passé mais
quand je vois des unes sur nos amis
catholiques où on fait passer les
catholiques pour des pédophiles
alors oui à la baie de philippe ça
existe oui mais dans toutes les
religions mais quand systématiquement à
ceux ci catholicisme à pédophilie bah ça
me dérange
de la même façon on associe la religion
musulmane aux terroristes de la même
façon qu'on associe nos amis juifs à
l'argent au fait d'être à demain moi ça
me dérange pas donc ça me blesse c'est
comme ça me laisse me dis que ça peut
aussi blessé mon voisin est donc si ça
baisse mon voisin c'est parce qu'il faut
peut-être s'arrêter là alors au nord
voilà j'attends tout des gens dire que
je suppose une société totalitaire n'en
faut être un peu plus si je le dis moi
je comprends qu'on prend la vie de jimmy
qui dit qu'on sablaise des gens n'a
passé que c'est pas drôle ça peut la
limite selon lé jury andré bercoff on
peut pas dire ça je crois que c'est un
problème extrêmement grave
il faut revenir à l'histoire alors oui
c'est toujours héros et aller vers
toujours une histoire bien où tu as fait
et est-ce que qui vais descendre et
géricault mais alain decaux et oui
absolument qui va décider de qui
blessent qui les juge moi je vais vous
dire un truc très simple c'est qu'à
partir du moment
normal juge on n'est pas dans une
société policière et les pales ce hit et
juridictionnelles je rappelle quelque
chose
pierre desproges il ya 30 ans 40 ans
celle il disait un moment donné ils
disent aimer le sommet on me dit que
quelques juifs se sont glissés dans la
salle et ben justement on a la vidéo est
parfait vous avez préparé l'émission
oui bien sûr dont vous avez beaucoup de
chance bercoff regarder
on me dit que des juifs se sont glissés
dans la salle
n'empêche qu'on ne m'ôtera pas de l'idée
que pendant la dernière guerre mondiale
de nombreux juifs ont une attitude
carrément hostiles à l'égard du régime
nazi
il est vrai que les allemands de leur
côté ne cachait pas une certaine
antipathie à l'égard des juifs mais
enfin ça n'était pas une raison pour
exacerber cette antipathie en armant une
étoile à sa veste pour montrer qu'on
n'est pas n'importe qui on est le peuple
élu et pourquoi j'irais pointé au
vélodrome d'hiver
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces wagons
sans banquette
12 6e inouïe juste un mot je voulais
continuer là-dessus aujourd'hui c'est
impensable aujourd'hui qu'il y aurait
que ça sur les juifs ou les musulmans
etc vous ayez 40 associations
là ils retourneraient vers ce sketch
argent il a raison et folie d'arte
sombrer non monsieur venu parce que dans
mon nom mais dont il dira qu'on arrête
de petites secondes peaux demandé aux
rabbins jeune âge déclin est ce qu est
ce que ça vous fait marrer vos statuts
ou est-ce que ça vous dérange
alors quand on le prend dans le contexte
de l'époque je pense que quelque chose
d'assez drôle parce que en réalité quand
je vois un sketch comme celui là je me
dis ce dont ils se moquent sont les
antisémites balajo effet que ça ouais
bien je pense que quand on analyse quand
on écoute ce qui dit c'est ça la réalité
c'est pas le fait de pointer les
quelques juifs dans la salle mais c'est
le fait de pointer le fait que dans
l'esprit de certains il puisse y avoir
quelque chose de dérangeant à ça et
l'humour c'est toujours lié à
l'intelligence est toujours lié à la
combe et compte sur vous pourrez rire
vous si vous étiez grâce à vous aurait
rigolé écoutez je pense que oui mais je
peux pas vous donner à vous n'étiez pas
dire persistait 86 à la pratique pour
amel série alors oui bonsoir oui bonsoir
assuré qu'à trouver c'est extrêmement
important est grave parce qu'aujourd'hui
il y a une tendance formidable qui dit
attendez faut plus parler de rien il va
faire très attention et hop
alors moi je vous dirais amour quand
même faut briser le maire de rien sans
vous laisser le philly à une volonté de
censure une volonté de police de la
pensée et je voudrais pas seulement sur
le giro même si ce sujet toutankhamon il
y a l'exposition toutankhamon croyait
lui parce que tant qu'à moi j'ai été
voir ce spectacle c'était une cata
j'aurais pu le voir tout acabit bizarre
on lit on y l'origine africain
toutankhamon
tout à coup et égyptien l'egypte est
l'égyptien c ou egypte c'est pas au pôle
nord c'est à l'afrique
leschi il ya eu un certain nombre de
choses qui consiste mais oui je veux
dire il y a eu des gens qui ont dit ces
racistes
vous avez oublié de dire que
toutankhamon et paix africains conneries
total qui a dit ça ya un groupe un
groupuscule qui a dit ça qui en a parlé
parce qu'elle n'est pas l'humour il a eu
des presses non non c'est très important
mais en fait célébration
bien placé à l'ailé robot mobile va défi
sur twitter est une
j'étudie tout en cas mon avis là il a 5
euros de plus autre casas et charlie
hebdo il ya eu 15 morts
parce que il s'est attaqué a appris la
bonne case mon nom il faut oublier c'est
pas un petit truc comme en même temps
que vous dites est pas une rigolade en
mai donc vous dites on peut se moquer
des religions pas je dit c'est tout on
peut se moquer de tout et c'est les gens
sont blessés
ils n'ont qu'à ne pas écouter voilà
c'est très simple on est dans un pays de
liberté c'est faux il à dire que c'est
la 6e' pas de passionner que ce soit
religion ou pas rien et au dessus pour
l'apa le le délit de blasphème n'existe
pas en france et heureusement parce que
c'est une démocratie on sait très bien
dans quelle fille il suffit de d'assurer
des religions pour être torturés ou
emprisonnés ou marie calme après j'aurai
tout en entendant un bruit très avantagé
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que je
pense qu'on est dans l'opposition de
sacrée la liberté d'expression elle est
sacrée dans notre pays par l'histoire et
on touche au sacré quand on touche aux
religions pour les croyants de dans
cette opposition des sacrés je suis
assez partagé parce que je me dis oh de
brand dans mon pays la france où la
liberté d'expression est sacrée on doit
pouvoir se moquer des religions mais en
même temps je considère que la moquerie
elle dérive souvent sur l'humiliation
sur le sentiment d' insulte sur même
j'ai envie de dire de l'obsession parce
qu'on a parfois des choix éditoriaux des
choix humoristique qui tourne à
l'obsession dans notre pays aujourd'hui
de qui on se demander si c'est encore
dans le sceau de l'humour on se demande
si ce ne sont pas des messages
subliminaux qui ont une dimension
politique
tu penses à côté c'est quoi quoi tient
qu'un exemple je pense par exemple à des
gens qui voient sous couvert
d'antisémitisme nos fans de l'humour
donc est en réalité ils prennent
toujours les juifs en obsession je pense
à ceux qui prennent toujours l'islam et
les musulmans
donc même s'il ya des gens qui en font
un fonds de commerce qui n'est plus
rigolo bien ce qui devrait effectivement
vrai faire ce que ça donne c'est pour ça
que merci je suis interdit de rêver ce
cépage et lahi commun et pas religieuse
mal de la réalité c'est que m'avait
encore une fois j'ai les sentiments faux
cul qu'on doit pouvoir effectivement
dans l'expression être libre dans notre
pays parce qu'il faut quand même dire
qu'en thaïlande et si tu te manque de
bouddha tu vas en prison aux etats-unis
ne pas tu peux te manquer de jésus à
l'épée mais je suis surtout que
maintenant ça excuse moi je te je te
donnerai les éléments il ya des gens qui
se sont fait dans certains états
américains
parce que chahuté de queue et d'un
certain pied musulmane tu peux pas te
manque effectivement de l'argent mais il
me semble moi il me semble que moi qui
suis croyant je me dis est-ce que -
sacré je dois m'imposer à autrui
je me pose la question est-ce que ce qui
est sacré pour moi je dois l'imposer à
celui qui ne partagent pas le même sacré
tu as pas très bon il sait qui on est
il ay que je vais pas le cacher je viens
de te dire est ce que la liberté
d'expression est une valeur sacrée dans
mon pays et que dans ma du truc les
mollahs je sais mais les amis les gars
je suis désolé très désolé
un sacré quoi tient la vertu d'être avec
les ordres qui est très clivant quoi
qu'à l'habitude le 2-2 de limiter aux
deux cas la démagogie quand je vous dis
que c'est un sujet car tuer le corbeau
chaise c'est qu'on peut pas sa fin c'est
vrai ce que vous dites pas qu on ne peut
pas s'exprimer sans offenser nom ne
traverse pas l'esprit mary moi c'est le
mot c'est l'humour
dommage d'abîmer yoplait chapelet on se
calme - il est une deux et moi je
viendrai l'humour c'est l'humour mais
c'est un mort et pendant que vous ayez d
une de charlie hebdo qui m'ont choqué
c'est pour ça que je vais demander
l'internement
simplement je vous disais que de ne pas
imposer effectivement donc son sacré à
autrui et peut-être que les croyants
quelles que soient les religions devrait
prendre de la distance et ben voilà avec
cette forme d'humour par effectivement
peut faire mal parfait